reject nation hello we're back at it
again
aaron looking like a cross between
luther and vin diesel
thanks for being here family
see we're here to watch the family we
ride together
we die together that's bad boys
so we're gonna watch umbrella academy
season two episode seven
i don't know if you guys have heard me
say this already but just in case
i'm gonna say it again what do you think
of my hair today does it kind of look
like klaus's
i wasn't going for it but when it was
done i was like hey it kind of looks
like klauses that's not what i wanted to
say
what i wanted to say is subscribe to the
real rejects and click that notification
bell so you can get notified when our
next umbrella academy reaction is up
youtube only allows for 10 minutes worth
of footage usually
sometimes no of footage from the show to
be included our full-length uncut
watchalongs are over at our patreon page
and instead of naming them all off today
here's all the shows that we cover
majority of them of the images i'm
showing you right now have reaction
highlights included at the same tier as
well as the watch along
look at all those shows i think i'm done
showing the shows now we also got a
weekly q a podcast
[Music]
oh snap d drop five oh snap he took car
grapes of ice and traveled five seconds
into 1982
what the [ __ ] was it i think that cat's
going to read that rabbit's ass
all right light and fun as always it's
not bleak at all
oh damn
oh [ __ ] oh damn oh jesus
psycho why [ __ ]
psychopath whoa holy [ __ ] oh
damn why are you going this far
why do you go so brutal oh my god why
did you just get a gun on the way man
this is so dark
damn son that was [ __ ] up
five that's not very polka of you now
it's brutal i'm worried about insanity
poor fish how to get your umbrella baby
poor fishy
listen the point is i'm not gonna let
you win
[Laughter]
my hair looks nothing like this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what if the twist is he actually thinks
he can get a threesome
oh no actually i need to give him
says
this will be my chance to murder a girl
god damn someone's getting someone's not
making out of that car or that trip
let's see if carl does something messed
up enough
or vania can murder him
problem solved the little boy's gonna
miss him
i'll be back soon you could rumor robert
kennedy
[Music]
oh the fish is alive for our agreement
this will get you and your siblings
back to 2019. you have 90 minutes
oh it's not gonna work nothing's
impossible
you prove that this morning when you
feel bored i need more time any more
time and people
oh damn you mother [ __ ]
they're not gonna go it'll be a very
disappointing show if they do yeah
they'll be a lot shorter
he is he is yeah okay i haven't seen an
interview with him but i was like i get
a british buy from this dude
it's like too american
[Laughter]
it's too clean
excuse me i was just wondering
oh lady oh my god
[Laughter]
you idiots
i would not mind a show with just those
they're going to save the world
oh she's going to see mommy
mother all back to being blonde all
12 members
you manipulative [ __ ] why would five
trust here
is there gonna be a coup i like this you
gotta see how she like got her way up to
the
like what got her to be handler in the
first place right yeah
it's this kind of attitude and scheming
she handled that situation
the benefits of having a five everything
will be back to normal
all right no more questions she's got
time to change that what about that
what about that jfk has been dead for
your whole life
[Music]
oh you don't know what's your fault
i'll kill you myself dude
who plays five he's incredible he's the
most lethal of all of them
this is his show
luther my hero
oh damn i love the sound effects on it
how it sounds like it's messing with
like his organs
yeah and he has very like slush
kind of quality to it how are his
mannerisms gonna change
that's your brother's dick yeah it is
that's klaus's dick though
we're just like oh gee i gotta collapse
his dick i got a dick
i can [ __ ] oh ben gets to have an
experience oh i used to eat again
he gets to taste taste again
people probably think he's tripping
right now
[Laughter]
well the gay side of club's gonna have
david and then
when ben's in him it's a great cycle
that's gonna happen
it works out
uh um before it gets out of hand
oh you bigot but it ain't natural
oh hard to go back spending time with
his mom
and his dad oh my god bonnie's going to
murder oh god
are you blackmailing here with your own
son and i do expect
you to be packed up
oh wow we're going to just kill him i
mean he could have handled that worse
other than the
you know the deep belief of homophobia
yes
it's not completely unreasonable what
he's asking you know very sinister way
going up he could have
he could have murdered her not defending
him all right saying that i could see
claire again
hey
okay superman
that was very sweet can i
can i smell your hair
oh right there
oh
[Music]
that's cool so if the fish needs the
body all right
it's probably not good to keep it there
why don't you keep it alive in the first
place
it was like a victory taunt
out of security what a dream job wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh why would klaus want to leave that
still has hope to save david's life
oh you're right
five and she has to leave anyway will
happen if you don't come with me a mom
and her eight-year-old son are not gonna
screw up the timeline five
they're in sickness
why do you get to decide you're the
reason we're stuck here in the first
place
if i did nothing we would all be dead
right now thanks to you
hmm
[Music]
don't do it guys oh power off you're
more scared of her
of course she's scared
can't you take her right
okay so the idea is that if they go
doomsday doesn't happen right
for any of them this timeline in the
other timeline that's what i'm assuming
okay
to use you too you know how hard it is
to trust people
your whole childhood was [ __ ]
why would you do that to me because it
happened to her as a child and her
people hurt people
oh elliot the toenails has a visual
reminder
[Laughter]
sure are taking their time i have time
to go to classes
make a hole
dude his arms are a lot bigger oh she
poisoned him don't trust her
no you
are god damn it i believed her
you want me to leave it's more than that
man
you can still go to dallas
um you know about obama right
you know about martin luther king right
i would take
you with you oh you
sweet mother effort you destroyed me
son of a [ __ ] okay yeah but she goes if
they all go the
the dooms it doesn't happen all right
like my mind's getting a little confused
yeah as far as we know yeah cause she
could be lying
oh no tell them a rumor
that's [ __ ] up how's your throat
oh god i'll explain when we get there no
no we need to leave
how did you pack everyone's stuff
hey okay she's listening oh [ __ ] this is
unexpected
okay oh [ __ ]
no no no no no no no don't do that
just take the can just leave just get up
oh no
oh oh no
those are great
god effects back again we're going to
bring you the flavor we're going to show
you how
what song is that what's the yeah i
don't know what song that is everybody
and we're back again
interesting way to bring in the
backstreet boys
can she not talk at all i assume not
no no raymond where's luther we're gonna
get luther in here
oh whoa okay
ouch jesus
whoa that is so weird
so trippy oh damn i love this this is so
whoa this is so dope
whoa can they see him they can't see him
though
i mean you're here no no
hell no no no no no not this oh god he
cannot
die by the hands of these guys
oh [ __ ] why don't you say kill himself
too oh my god this is so
disturbing holy oh god oh no
damn the swede oh damn he doesn't want
to do it
wow all right now i'll take care of him
now
right did you let him leave
what the [ __ ] oh they're popping carl
aren't they they're gonna get an
accident uh oh
oh my god i didn't really pick up on
that
no way yeah no way
that's what i was thinking when she said
she used to make her own team sort of
twisted way of keeping him in her life
time to show [ __ ] that you got some
powers show her what you got but she
breathed life
into the boys the boy might do oh okay
oh [ __ ]
oh you're so badass
oh this is this is all a big surprise
for her
oh my god
she's like what is she
oh oh oh that's all right wherever she's
captured she can
break out
what if they hit on her head brings her
back oh
damn oh damn let's talk about it really
quick and film the next episode
this has got to be one of the easiest
shows i've ever
reacted to i don't know how i could
possibly communicate what i mean by that
it takes me like a few minutes and
i'll start like really forgetting about
the camera being here
and i'll be so wrapped in the show at
the same time it's still like
bringing out stuff in me
it's such a damn good show i love a
great ticking clock
concept movies or shows like there's
always a good clock and this episode had
a really defined one right at the top
within 90 minutes
yeah it keeps the pacing really sharp
yeah fives
massacre at the top though holy moley
mole mole mole
wow he whoa talk about it aaron
he went full uh yeah he won a full
psycho he won
full uh full uh jack from the shining on
his full
full axe murder that was nuts i feel
like you know
he had that whole thing with the handler
of this is it i only did it for my
family you seem like you like it though
yeah
it seems like he's a little addicted to
it i know he was uh killing people
because he was an assassin before he ran
back to his families but
i got the vibe that this was different
this was a lot more a lot more gruesome
a lot more
vulgar than what he would normally do i
mean you could just sneak in a gun and
bang bang bang but you were like
getting all kinds of person like with
the axe and the slicing
like this seems good this seems like the
appropriate thing to murder
yeah people even with the fish head guy
he like hit him a couple times before he
likes taunted him and then you know
i know he doesn't like the bureau of
course not but
i don't feel there's a bit of a
cathartic experience and a bit of a
release for him
yeah i i got the vibe he he liked it
yeah yeah
you can tell that he liked him but he's
like i gotta stop doing this because
because this is how he likes i like
murdering people
viciously but yeah this 90-minute
concept the handler i like her a lot
this season
i like how you set up with her in a way
that allows you to see the way her mind
works and her scheming works to see like
oh that no wonder a woman like her got
into this position
give me like little finger vibes right
yeah
everyone throws reference he's not
talking about
actual physical little fingers yeah
don't
get it don't hold that up i see your
mind's going
[Laughter]
freaks it's an episode like this of why
i love this show so much because
it's the same similar reasons to why i
love doom patrol it's easy to look at
this and call it a superhero show i
don't want to make a big comparison to
doom patrol right now yeah
it's more than that it's really just
about a dysfunctional family who
happens to have super powers it's a lot
more compelling
i do think they do vary in the ways they
tell those stories but i feel like
they're both very engaging
yeah it's like you you get this scenario
where there's this end of the world
apocalypse so yeah they have to
save the world the little missions in
every episode and what they're doing
is so much more personal and not real
and the episodes don't really seem like
they're about being a hero
yeah no no i think the only ones that
kind of identify as a hero are diego and
i guess luther i guess not even not
even not anymore i love the conflict of
some of them being like ah should i go
back to 2019
because you know a lot of that like if
i've only been there for a few days he's
not settled here
exactly what 10 days is said when they
started off
yeah some something like that because
for the rest of them a lot of them have
built a life there
vania's with [ __ ] freaking allison's
married and helping them with the civil
rights movement you would think
at first thought that i think at the
first thought you would think initially
that
it would be a no-brainer for them to
leave but then you remember all the
things they've been through in this year
and you're like yeah that makes sense
that we want to stay
even with klaus you know yeah he's built
a cult he's also got the david situation
yeah because david he feels like he has
a chance to kind of
reunite with the the person he loves i
loved
all that stuff with ben embody and
klaus's body hey i love the effects of
the
siamese twin body it's kind of like it's
not
body horror but it kind of is like a fun
version of body horror with the with the
body coming out of him
yeah yeah yeah like they definitely use
that that kind of
concept and other other mediums of ghost
inhabiting bodies but this had a very
unique flavor to it like the sound
effect
kudos to those performers man the whole
thing with klaus going down the hallway
and like the effect of ben coming out of
him like obviously he wasn't there for
that when they shot yeah
so just just really living that out like
that's really impressive on that actor
but i love the sense of wonder that it
provided with ben being able to finally
have his
senses back intact yeah that must have
been really surreal for him i can only
imagine being in that scenario
i can feel again yeah and then having a
interesting takeaway there with jill
like that was so unexpected
it's like beautiful and tragic at the
same time because like he's
he's getting to experience this girl
he's like basically been stalking this
whole time yeah
but she's not into ben she's not in
dimensions in the clouds yeah
okay so class is bisexual uh yeah that's
what i was gathering
all right i thought he was just he's so
hundred percent homosexual but he's
bisexual okay
i think he's i think he's like a free
spirit he does what he wants it's like
yeah yeah it's like prince does whatever
he wants so he's heterosexual
the way the scene with carl played out
was very different and
you know there's a there's a side of
that where i can see his perspective
of having this old like i'm not i don't
like carl and i don't agree with his
you know point of view towards
homosexuality
yeah cancel greg kids
that's his wife the time he's living in
and his wife is technically having an
affair under his roof
you know he has a right to be upset now
the whole thing with getting rid of
harlan and
sending him away uh all that stuff and
then all the you know the homophobia
element
is all messed up you know i thought it
would have been worse in the threatening
department i thought he was like gonna
have a gun or do something like sadistic
or something right i don't think we
we i don't think he's like he's that
much of a savage he's he's
like a civilized texan man i thought he
would have like cracked
it i thought it would have been a little
bit more overt about it but then you see
that he is a bit of a
coward in a lot of ways yeah very
sinister in his way
very manipulative sneaky in his way of
trying to
resolve this issue i think what this
show does a great job at doing
is handling the inner conflict of how
these characters would respond during
situations like this
as annoying of a plot point it is you
know from the audience perspective and
rooting for vanya and [ __ ] to make
their getaway
of her leaving the note makes perfect
sense she would do that like this
of course this is very conflicting and
she doesn't even know the full extent of
the details as to
why vanya is insisting they get the [ __ ]
out of dodge right now you know
she doesn't understand the whole picture
this is just sprung on to her
yeah it made me happy that she trusted
her though in any situation i was like i
can't imagine somebody doing this but
something about that actress just makes
it feel like yeah i've been really
believable that that character and these
two people would
go and and venture off and leave like
that i
loved ellen page's performance this
entire episode
yeah this entire episode whatever weird
like criticisms i had no i don't think
they were weird i thought they were
actually perfectly valid the criticisms
i had towards her
kind of laid-back attitude in the last
episode her performance here
she to me her and five were the the top
two performers in this episode
yeah she did have a very kind of strong
presence in this one
they embraced that like on edge sticking
time clock
uh paranoia attitude heist high tension
high suspense
i feel like they really understood the
time limit on this episode i feel like i
feel like yes
and but in other aspects there were
times like five games of change and
diego burying a whole body
before the before their time limit i was
like okay
in some aspects it felt like they were
rushing out the other aspects they're
like okay we can
have an episode well i feel like i'm
talking about just acting in general i
think
i think the writing and the
circumstances of yeah i mean movies and
shows generally do that where you're
like there's no way
you would have gotten all this done in
90 minutes right exactly
but the way it felt kind of so
supportive by the end of the episode you
knew that they were going to
try to be together well like the scene
with five and vanya
was brilliant yeah them catching each
other
they're both being the most lethal
characters in this show they're both the
most lethal
and they're both the reason they're in
the 60s
her apocalyptic ways forced five to go
down its mouth into the 60s and so just
hate when your sisters have that
apocalyptic tendency but
i love how all the blame that whenever
people get mad they're all mad at five
never like ever bonnie's innocent she's
our member she didn't do it but
yeah i think they're all much more
sympathetic to vanya because they know
the circumstances that really letter
to that right they all feel the guilt of
that the swedes i
really thought that was a very
compelling death scene
when the other sweden brother died you
could really see his his face
like the the conflict like him murdering
his brother but him really not wanting
to do it
struggling to not do it and then yeah
but having to do
like a demonstrates the extent of
allison's powers like
of course we knew she's capable of that
demonstrates how lethal
she is as much as we don't love the
swedes personally i felt like i couldn't
really win
in that situation with the swede brother
leaving because if they both just died i
would have been like
that's it right all that with the swedes
and that's it
that's how they go out right and then
with him getting away alice and just
letting him get away but was also like
really why did you just let him get away
made no sense
like why would you not tell him to kill
himself too you're perfectly fine with
brother killing brother
but not so like [ __ ] yeah just tell
them did they ever get
a specific commission to go kill allison
i don't remember that i don't remember
that either
i don't know i think i think they're
just trying to find their way to diego
but at the same time i'm like what does
it make sense to just try to kill
allison and raymond it kind of came out
of nowhere but
the fight scene was kind of cool but
yeah we got some good cliffhangers here
that we got to get into for the next
episode
so why theorize even more i mean we got
handler diego
part of the lila team don't trust lila
man
vanya's secrets are to that actress who
plays lila's great she's
fantastic i but like that's how you lie
i love the way you lie i can't tell you
what it really is tell you what it feels
like
one criticism i often have with movies
and shows is when characters lie
it's like the actors playing it in a way
where i'm like
it's obviously you're lying you know
right that she played it so much as if
she didn't have
an ulterior motive or that there was
like something sneaky about the drink
exactly brilliantly played i thought she
nailed it oh my god i also love the
scene with diego
and ben yeah then reuniting is great i
love how
i love how this is wonderful how the
characters in the show just like accept
information
he's gotta roll with the weird man it's
like it's all unexpected at this point
it's the lifestyle they rolled into lots
look forward to the next episode
let's get into it oh yeah
subscribe click that notification bell
check us out on patreon
okay this is a youtube video page of the
day shout out
thinking about who i wanted to shout out
right now who was just on my mind at
heart and i wanted to say jason dolan
jason i don't think you watched this
show i know you watch a lot of netflix
and you catch up on a lot of movies i
was actually
this might sound weird went on a run in
about a 95 degree weather
so i still sweating sweat out the
hour and a half later on my way back for
some reason he just popped into my mind
and i was thinking about how like you've
been there for me countless times
there's been so many times
where i'll just randomly call you about
like i need a piece of advice on
something or
i'm looking for help on something and
then we end up talking for like an hour
this has happened
more times than i i've lost count by
this point i can't think of too many
people in my life who are just there for
me i got like a small handful and you're
one of them who's just there for me
pretty much any time unexpected
right at the most random moments right
now at this particular moment
i'm just feeling really grateful to know
you i love you dude
thank you so much for terrific guys
seriously every time i feel like anytime
we come across you with somebody else
you're usually helping them out
you know and that speaks volumes to your
character so like yeah
there aren't enough thank yous in the
world for you jason dolan and then one
day we will
just work together properly yeah see you
buddy
[Music]